voilà c'est lors de notre second débat
vous le savez on choisit volontairement
décalée de l'actualité c'est un débat de
société qui nous mène ce soir dans les
couloirs des ministères pour découvrir
le rôle des cabinets de conseil privé
après les révélations par le site
politico et par le canard enchaîné de
l'utilisation du cabinet américain
mckinsey par le ministère de la santé le
sénat a ouvert une commission d' enquête
sur ce thème mode rêve états
en janvier le gouvernement a reconnu
avoir sollicité un cabinet privé
mckinsey pour organiser la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vite un
service facturé 2 millions d'euros à
l'état assez pour faire naître une
polémique pourquoi faire appel à ces
cabinets privés faut-il y voir un aveu
de faiblesse de l'administration des
questions auxquelles tente de répondre
une commission d' enquête lancée par le
groupe communiste au sénat mais d'abord
qu'est ce qu'un cabinet de conseil privé
c'est une structure qui dispose de
ressources importantes
pour analyser certaines situations d'
expertise particulière qui sont
d'ailleurs très utile souhaite aux
entreprises et pour des états on a des
cabinets qui conseille de très nombreux
états à travers toute la planète ce qui
est une force mais qui peut présenter
aussi des questionnements pour nous
notamment en matière de souveraineté de
devenir de nos données
autre question que se pose la commission
denquête dans quels domaines
interviennent ces fameux cabinet on sait
qu'ils sont très présents à l'hôpital on
sait aussi qu'en un an pendant la crise
l'état a passé 28 commandes pour un
montant total de 25 millions d'euros
mais cela pourrait aller beaucoup plus
loin ce n'est que la face émergée d'un
iceberg beaucoup beaucoup plus grand
parce qu'en fait ces montants sont
éclatés dans l'ensemble des ministères
dans certaines directions
interministérielles et notre premier
travail c'est de faire la cartographie
tout cela pour en apprécier vraiment
d'importance d'après les premières
personnes auditionnées les cabinets
privés seraient omniprésent dans le
secteur public depuis la fin des années
90 les grandes firmes du conseil ont
créé des départements services publics
peuplée de hauts fonctionnaires et
d'ingénieur d'état quelle débauche
dernière question sans réponse pour
l'instant comment l'état a pu devenir si
dépendants de ces cabinets c'est ce que
la commission denquête va tenter
d'expliquer lé influence croissante des
cabinets de conseils voilà le thème de
notre débat avec valérie boyer bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice l ère des
bouches du rhône membre de la commission
d' enquête justement sur cette influence
des cabinets de conseil privé sur les
politiques publiques foulée pierru
bonsoir bienvenue
sociologue spécialiste des politiques de
santé et chercheurs au cerap centre
d'études et de recherches
administratives politiques et non sial
alors je suis maintenant à 1 rennes à
l'école des hautes études en santé
publique école des hautes études en
santé publique très bien j'avais une
info qui datait un peu donc voilà suis
désolé merci de la précision à fait le
genre d'être juriste à l'opinion à
l'opinion me voilà rassurée bienvenue
avons aussi bon soir avec nous françois
ecalle quête au fonctionnaire ancien
rapporteur de la cour des comptes
fondateur du site fip echos.fr et qui
est avec nous en duplex bonsoir françois
ecalle merci d'être là a répondu à notre
invitation laetitia cru pas toujours à
mes côtés évidemment pourquoi fallait-il
créer cette commission denquête valérie
boyer c'était quoi l'urgence alors
c'était bas l'urgence peut-être pour
savoir et j'avoue que c'est peut-être le
recours aux cabinets conseils notamment
le cabinet mckenzie qui avait défrayé la
chronique moi j'avais interrogé emmanuel
macron en février 2021 pour lui demander
pourquoi cette firme américaine avait
avait eu comment dire les yeux de
chimène de départ du gouvernement et la
réponse que monsieur strauss szames
avait
renvoyé c'était écoutez c'est très
intéressant comme question je vais en
parler au ministre de la santé qui vous
répondra et depuis février 2000
j'attends toujours donc voilà donc moi
je vois là je m'étais interrogé je me
suis demandé pourquoi on a recours au
cabinet conseil ok
mais peut-être pas cet auteur est ce
qu'il n'ya pas de compétences à
l'administration si oui quelles
compétences manquent d'une part est-ce
que qu'elle est je voulais je voulais
aussi connaître la nature de la commande
le contenu de la commande d'une part et
d'autre part savoir si cette commande
une fois qu'elle avait été réglée avait
été bien évidemment exécuté avoir des
détails sur la façon dont on travaille
pourquoi parce qu'il me semble
totalement
normal au moment où on essaye de faire
ou on fait des efforts ce qui est
totalement nova bhl sur l'utilisation
des fonds publics et de l'administration
qu'on sache ce qui se passe avec ses
cabinets conseils ça me semble logique
vous savez on compare souvent par
exemple l'hôpital public l'hôpital privé
il ya même des outils pour ça on compare
on compare par exemple la sécurité
sociale et les mutuelles en disant que
la sécurité sociale gère très très bien
parce que eu égard à la masse de de
commandes qu'elle passe le coût de son
personnel est très faible quels sont les
outils pour savoir quelle est l'utilité
des caminotti ça pose pas mal de
questions ce pas de questions
d'utilisation de la gentille
souveraineté j'allais le dire ou mme
hotte et les mots de la bouche je
voudrais savoir frédéric pierru si c'est
un phénomène en croissance en
augmentation d'après vous oui parce que
j'avais entendu le ministre vers andy
dire que finalement tous les
gouvernements de gauche de droite
avaient eu recours à des cabinets de
conseil
il me semble que c'est une partie de
l'histoire
en fait il ya eu une augmentation
quantitative et un saut qualitatif
voilà c'est à dire qu'à partir des
années 2000 2002
comme dirait mon collègue
philippe bès politiste à sciences po la
réforme de l'état rentre en mode
industriel et là on voit arriver
effectivement les multi nationales du
conseil d'accor qui se traduisent par
exemple par les audits copé de
modernisation de l'action publique et je
pense que le vrai décollage et la vraie
mutation qualitative
c'est la rgpp la révision générale des
politiques publiques séquence
2007 2008 c'est ce à quoi un sixième
mandat avec l'éjection nicolas sarkozy
où on voit en fait des très hauts
fonctionnaires notamment de l'inspection
générale des finances et des gens de
mckinsey capgemini boston consulting
group etc
n'ont pas pu évaluer des politiques
publiques plus tôt
réfléchir à la réorganisation de
l'administration
voilà et depuis ça n'a fait qu'augmenter
donc j'étais surpris surpris vraiment
effectivement il ya toujours eu des
cabinets de conseil dans la réforme de
l'état mais il y à un saut quantitatif
et qualitatif dans les années 2000
jouets consomme sur l'utilisation du
cabinet mckinsey sur la pendant cette
crise sanitaire puisque c'est finalement
ce qui a lancé la commission denquête ce
qu'ils ont aussi notre notre débat en
fait le genre est ce qu est ce que vous
ça vous choque finalement qu'on est con
qu'on ait pu faire appel à ce cabinet de
conseil ce qui m'a choqué c'est plutôt
la désorganisation de l'état au début de
la crise le cabinet mckinsey est arrivé
mi-décembre à peu près dans un milieu
assez chaotique sur l'organisation alors
d'abord mckinsey a été mandatée sur la
logistique l'organisation la mise en
place des centres de vaccination la
campagne au premier trimestre est de
l'année précédente bon il trouve que
nous trois mois les problèmes étaient
réglés déjà nous on avait accès plus ou
moins rapidement à une dose de
vaccination dans les dents des
vaccinodromes notamment qui ont été
mises en place il y avait une
organisation services de l'état étaient
extrêmement complexes et mckinsey est
venu pour apporter un peu de rationalité
mais ce qu'ils font pour le public comme
ils le font pour le privé ces cabinets
font appel à une expertise technique
reconnue dans le monde du privé comme
dans l'eau du puits qui et c'est vrai
que ça fait vingtaine d'années quand
vous dites quoi pourquoi le public s'en
priverait d'une certaine façon pourquoi
le public centre est le problème moi je
comprends le
l'intérêt qu'il peut y avoir du
législateur parce qu'il ya un vrai
problème de transparence en réalité ça
fait dix ans qu'on essaie d'avoir des
chiffres à peu près clair sur
l'utilisation de ces cabinets on a
beaucoup de mal à avoir la cour des
comptes a fait un rapport fin 2014 là
dessus mais ça date un peu on n'a
toujours pas de transparence de l'état
sur l'utilisation des sommes a
logiquement combien ça coûte
est ce que je comprends tout à fait ce
que vous dites et vous avez raison sur
les résultats néanmoins par rapport aux
vaccinodromes moi je l'avais interroger
le gouvernement je me souviens je leur
ai fait une lettre de six pages
au moment au pic du premier confinement
parce que j'ai été quand même très
surprise qu'on n'utilise pas un outil
que tout le monde connaît il y en a même
deux notre carte vitale et les
pharmacies je rappelle qu'il y à une
pharmacie pour 2500 habitants que les
pharmaciens ou à six millions de
personnes par jour et que ils n'ont pas
été utilisés pour vacciner est ce qui
était relativement facile puisque nous
avions les cabinets dentaires été fermés
besoin de faire appel à un cabinet de
conseil ou alors je n'ai toujours pas eu
de réponse du gouvernement savait sûr il
y avait
oui mais il ya des vaccins des vaccins
qui demandaient des frigos je rappelle
quand même qu'il y avait une possibilité
d'utiliser les pharmacies pour une
grande partie et il y avait aussi la
possibilité et ça a été fait en premier
dans les bouches-du-rhône d'utiliser
pour les analyses les laboratoires de
médecine vétérinaire alors dans les
bouches du rhône dans sa salle du phare
dont mais la polémique politique bidon
alors merci en clair merci à l'action
on a des laboratoires vétérinaires
alors je veux dire c'est laquelle il est
posé on n'a pas encore atteint
vétérinaire pouvaient être utilisés à
partir du moment où il avait un message
de fumel reprendre la main merci à les
renvoyer pour donner la parole à
françois items quand même pas encore
exprimé sur ce dossier précis en
législation de mckinsey et puis sur le
principe général françois ecalle est-ce
que c'est pas quand même une sorte de
constat d'échec pour la haute conscience
fonction publique que d'aller chercher
un cabinet de conseil privé non je pense
qu'il faut avoir sur ce sujet une
approche pragmatique
l'état peut avoir besoin de faire appel
aux conseils de sociétés spécialisées
exactement comme pour les entreprises
d'ailleurs parce que soit il n'a pas les
compétences soient tout simplement il a
besoin d'un regard extérieur c'est ceci
était le conseil voit des tas
d'entreprises d'autres administrations
d'autre détails peuvent apporter des
idées utiles maintenant il arrive aussi
que on demande des choses ces sociétés
le conseil que l'état pourrait faire
lui-même parce qu'il a les compétences
en interne et il arrive que les services
qu'elles rendent ne sert à rien moi la
cour des comptes j'en ai vu beaucoup des
marchés le conseil j'ai tout vu j'ai vu
des marchés comme ça et qui était très
utile des conseils qui était
effectivement utilisées il répondait à
un besoin je vais aussi vu des marchés
le conseil qui ne servait à rien en
général d'ailleurs les temps sont
partagés c'est parce que
l'administration n'a pas su définir son
besoin ou parce qu'elle n'a pas su
encadrer le cabinet en question mais
c'est aussi parfois parce que le cabinet
en question n'a pas fait ce qu'on lui a
demandé de faire donc je crois qu'il
faut être très pragmatique sur cette
question moi ça ne me choque pas que
l'état ait demandé à m kinsey je connais
pas ce marché mais a priori ça ne me
choque pas que l'état ait demandé à m
une scène j'ai donné des conseils y'a
pas de logiciel de logistique si j'ai
bien compris il n'y a pas de compétences
logistiques dans les services de l'état
sauf dans les armées mais la logistique
militaire c'est quand même un peu
particulier a priori
non en effet servi à rien pierru sûr pas
aux jours donnera la parole juste après
valérie boyer mais sur sur ce point
précis est-ce que vous pensez que
mckinsey avait une compétence
particulière pour traiter de d'une
politique de vaccination ni au coeur du
problème c'est à dire que on a beaucoup
fustigé les les ars
on ne pas avoir été assez réactive trop
bureaucratique etc
mais la réalité c'est que les ars ont
été
[Musique]
je dirais vidés de leur contenu et de
leur compétence et on est au coeur du
sujet c'est à dire que en fait pour moi
le recours croissant aux cabinets de
conseil est le symptôme du fait que les
décideurs politiques et administratifs
n'ont plus confiance dans les
professionnels de santé et dans leurs
troupes en fait voilà c'est à dire
qu'une fois qu'on a est vide et je
dirais l'administration déconcentrée de
l'état d'un point de vue sanitaire
effectivement on a recours à mckinsey
voilà donc ce que vous dites on a fait
un débat sur l'hôpital public il ya
quelques jours sur ce plateau est ce
pareil qu'on faisait c'est con à 30-35 %
de personnels administratifs dans les
hôpitaux donc on peut pas dire qu'on est
sous administrée dans les hôpitaux
français mais amy de quoi parle-t-on en
fait oui on parle
d'une inflation
d'administration de contrôle dans les
hôpitaux les cabinets conseils sont très
présents dans les hôpitaux
restructurations hospitalières etc
mais les agences régionales de santé et
j'ai piloté le numéro de la revue de
l'ena sur le sujet
son exemple en fait c'est une
administration qui est pauvre à qui on a
demandé de rendre des emplois des eaux
tp comme ils disent voilà et c est que
en fait les les gens qui sont sur le
terrain n'y sont plus en fait voilà et à
35% d'administratifs dans les hôpitaux
et qui en fait sont pas sur le terrain
et qui font appel à des cabinets quand
vous arriverez sans être à
100% d'administratifs bon kid dont le
boulot et de contrôle et dont les
consultants et de contrôler le boulot
des professionnels ça s'appelle marcher
sur la tête à un mollet tissait du
toujours de ce cabinet mckinsey y en
ad'autres un des dégâts et mais parce
qu'il ya un lien et on va dire un peu
particulier par le don de semis la wii
et notamment dans l'histoire d'emad
attractif j'ai rien contre la chine
c'est moi alors non mais c'est parce que
il est lié au chef de l'état et leye de
pulco fait oui ou d'années depuis que
la commission attali je veux juste je
vous raconte un petit
si je peux en placer une donc en 2015
c'est le site politico à l canard
enchaîné ensuite qui ont révélé qu
effectivement il y avait un lien entre
ce cabinet et emmanuel macron notamment
dans l'élaboration du projet de loi
macron 2 donc quand il était ministre de
l'économie il faisait déjà appel aux
services de ce cabinet est donc on
apprend à cette occasion qu'en fait il a
rencontré un membre particulièrement de
ce cabinet dans la commission attali en
2008 et c'est jacques attali café fait
appel à ce cabinet avec accenture avec
d'autres un bien sûr emmanuel macron
solide amitié si l'histoire d'hommes et
finalement il va continuer avec cet
homme là est donc ce cabinet là avec un
associé qui est devenu voilà quelqu'un
qui me dit qu'il a la kinsey voilà pas
là qu'il en qui il avait confiance et le
cabinet l'at-il aider pour sa campagne
oui l'ancien bien sûr il est né il a été
là pendant toute la campagne il ya
encore là maintenant ils vivent là après
une fois que manuel macron s'est
installé à l'elysée il a fait appel à ce
cabinet pour plusieurs projets mais ce
qui m'étonne c'est que pour le moment
personne n'a demandé à emmanuel macron
la nature du rapport de la relation
qu'il entretenait avec ce cabinet et on
a demandé c'est vrai vous l'aviez dit
boyer on a demandé au ministre de la
santé oms priori ne sais pas expliquer
mais olivier vers on l'a fait à
l'assemblée nationale le 9 février
dernier regardez
bah oui on a du talent donc privé
monsieur députés on a du talent dans le
secteur privé on a du talent de secteur
public quand on fait que du public ont
dit ou fait pas appel au privé quand on
fait appel au privé on dit pourquoi le
public fait pas et quand on fait appel
aux deux c où l'on fait appel trop à
l'intro à l'autre moi je ne sais plus
aux députés je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ya des règles ces règles sont
évidemment respectés y compris les
règles de transparence
bon alors la question c'est ça est-ce
que c'est transparent est ce que c'est
illégal ou pas ou est ce que c'est moral
ou pas est-ce que la question se situe
dans la légalité ou insultant bon moi
j'irais pas sur la moralité
demandé à emmanuel macron je suis pas
d'accord avec vous c'est paul c'est pas
la moralité c'est l'efficacité la
question qui se pose c'est l'efficacité
dans les forces de l'état raphaël
legendre mais c'est vrai c'est qu'il
commence à y faire appel à un cabinet
privé ça permet à l'état d'être plus
efficace sur certaines missions message
est différent ce sont les deux offices à
ces jeunes entendaient
j'en ai demandé quand même que mckinsey
a été embauché dans la crise parce que
emmanuel macron et 7 associé de mckinsey
étaient tous les deux co rapporteurs du
rapport attali en 2007-2008 ex espace
rive c'est pas quelques échanges de
faveur sais pas qui
je trouve ça assez perdition en réalité
parce que maxime c'est sûr très classe
qualifié comme le meilleur un des
meilleurs
défenses est une rencontre entre deux
hommes c'est tout c'est surtout un
service etc il se rend compte qu'en sont
relativement jeunes et qui décide
ensuite de faire le j'ai d'ailleurs on
peut c'est intéressant à fait le genre
parce qu'on peut dire que dans dans la
stratégie d'un cabinet de conseil c'est
aussi intéressant de rentrer en contact
avec bien jeune haut fonctionnaire et
gens vont peut-être devenir des
personnalités le
conseil parce qu'il y en a combien des
fonctionnaires qui pantouflent dans le
cabinet de conseil tout à l'heure à un
moment donné à un moment donné ça aussi
c'est quand même une information
intéressante j'espère qu'on le saura
dans la commission denquête même si je
sais ça n'a rien de répréhensible mais
c'est un problème de transparence on
peut pas dire d'un côté que
l'administration est dépourvu dépouillé
etc et de l'autre côté retrouver des
personnes qui travaillent dans des
cabinets de conseil qui reviennent dans
l'administration et le noir vient de la
faire parce que ce manque de
transparence est en train de nourrir
tous les fantasmes kong étude mckinsey
c'est une entreprise qui vraiment réputé
sur la place comme une des meilleures et
ils l'ont montré dans la crise ont été
très efficaces il ya eu 28 missions dans
la crise dont il n'y a absolument pas
que mc insee l'état fait travailler
l'ensemble des cabinets de conseil est
née museler ou à noter avec aucun des
cabinets le problème c'est qu'on ne sait
pas combien sont payés le problème c'est
la hausse et 28 missions 25 millions
d'euros de contrats pour huiler
défense d'abord on voudrait voir les
chiffres de bercy la direction du budget
savoir chaque année est que ce volume de
contrats et en os est en baisse est ce
que l'état achète bien c'est à dire est
qu'il est assez qualifiés au sein de son
administration pour lire correctement un
devis est ce qu'il en a pour son argent
à ce que chaque euro d'argent public
dépensés pour ces contrats est un euro
utile ça n'est pas toujours le cas vous
avez souvent des compétences en interne
dans administration mais il n'y a pas
d'outil au sein même de l'administration
pour trouver ses compétences et c'est
pour ça que peut-être que des fois on a
en fait appel à ce cabinet alors
concourir sur différé en 2018 a répondu
alors chers oui et on est 50 et 200
millions par an voilà alors le cas le 2
le rapport de la cour des comptes à ces
deux buts me casse qui parle de montants
facturés sur deux ans entre 2011 et 2016
c'est intéressant voilà le classement
des cabinets de conseil qui ont été le
plus utilisé par l'état pendant ces deux
années c'est cap gemini qui arrive
largement en tête pour 55 millions
d'euros c'est bearingpoint mckinsey à 19
millions rôle antérieur c'est un cabinet
allemand 17 millions e regroupe 14 et
publicis conclut consultant 11 millions
et donc j'en viens à la question de la
souveraineté parce que dans cette
missive il a maintenant deux cabinets
anglo-saxons tiens un candidat encore
candidat à peu près à l'élection
présidentielle c'est arnaud montebourg
qui avait évoqué cette question c'était
au mois de septembre dernier au micro
d'europe 1 nous avons un sujet de
réaffirmation de notre pays par exemple
peut-on accepter que tous les grands
cabinets de conseil mckinsey les grandes
banques les fonds d'investissement
goldman sachs
et installe niang qui sont soumis au
patriot a ouï dire que la totalité
informations qui circulent dans ces
cabinets sont directement capturés et
sont sous législation américaine
ces cabinets volet sécurité ce sont ces
cabinets qui travaille avec l'état
aujourd'hui les grandes entreprise
stratégique nous devons décider la mise
à l'écart françois ecalle je rappelle
que vous êtes ancien rapporteur de la
cour des comptes est-ce que ça pose une
vraie question souveraineté pour
que la plupart de ces cabinets de
conseil sont des cabinets heureusement
étrangers il y avait beaucoup
d'américains il ya un allemand en effet
roland berger j'allais français aussi
mais ils sont souvent beaucoup plus
petits ils n'ont pas les compétences
après je pense pas que les informations
qu'on leur donne soit ils utilisent je
dirais de manière contraire aux intérêts
de la france mais revenir sur le sujet
budgétaire
on n'y a pas de transparence mais le
problème c'est que l'organisation
comptable de l'état ne permet pas en
réalité de savoir combien quel est le
montant des commandes passées par là ces
sociétés de conseil il n'y a pas dans la
nomenclature budgétaire une ligne
dépensent pour les cabinets conseils et
c'est pour ça que dans son rapport 2015
la cour des comptes a été obligé de
faire un recensement particulier elle a
interrogé les administrations peut faire
ça une fois et a trouvé ce chiffre de
150 millions mais c'est le fun chicon
car elle donc quand on dit ça augmente
et ça augmente elle céda on n'en sait
strictement rien maintenant je peux vous
dire aussi d'expérience de la cour des
comptes c'est que quand on sait que ces
marchés sont en effet souvent stratégie
très sensible moi je contrôle les
entreprises publiques
j'allais souvent parce que entreprise
par entreprise ministère par ministère
on arrive à savoir quels sont les
marchés conseil qui ont été passés plus
important donc j'allais assez souvent
les voir corner j'ai comme j'ai dit à
l'heure j'ai trouvé tout j'ai donc j'ai
trouvé aussi des marchés irrégulier j'ai
fait condamner le président d'une grande
entreprise publique pour
de deux choix d'un prestataire de
conseil qui n'était pas régulier
et donc ça la cour des comptes regard
souvent ça alors je dresse sur cette
question de la souveraineté on a compris
françois et qu'elle disait que ce
n'était pas forcément une question
centrale qu'est ce que vous en pensez
valérie boyer moi je pense que c'est une
question importante je suis partage pas
son avis je alors il ya eu une double
souveraineté il ya celle j'allais dire
c'est la souveraineté de
l'administration qui j'arrive pas à
comprendre avec la qualité quand même
des fonctionnaires et des hauts
fonctionnaires que nous avons qu'on ne
puisse pas trouver dans ces proportions
là des personnes compétentes alors
honnêtement je reviens excusez moi
l'exemple de la vaccination s'il faut
attendre le cabinet pour savoir comtois
utiliser tel laboratoire mais c'est
juste hallucinant
les ars étaient là pour fait cela on
avait bien on avait des compétences on
avait des compétences aussi avec notre
réseau extraordinaire de médecine
libérale et de pharmacies libérales et
moi je suis jeune je ne comprends
toujours pas comment
on à l'organisation on a aussi des
outils qui sont incroyables dans le
domaine de la santé comme ceux de
l'assurance maladie et je pense
notamment à la carte vitale qu'on a
absolument pas utilisé pour cette
vaccination je dirais la double loin
d'avoir une fessée la douleur sur la
question en fait c'est alors en interne
c'est c'est en interne et puis à
l'extérieur bien évidemment qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire de ces données nous les
exploite pas de façon optimale déjà pour
me pour mener des politiques de santé
publique néanmoins regarder on a alors
qu'on a on a la carte vitale on a
développé le l'outil du pass sanitaires
et tous antico vide on a un instrument
on sent les même pas servi de cette
carte pour pouvoir mettre à jour enfin
le dossier médical qu'on a toujours pas
pour pouvoir mettre à jour nos
vaccination pour pouvoir mettre des
informations dessus on est obligé de
créer un système parallèle on ne se sert
pas de ce qui existe déjà et de ce qui
est déjà quand même qu'il ya dix jours
déjà des outils extraordinaires bien
entendu parler un peu plus excusez moi
je les termine plus toutes les
informations sur les données de santé
qu'on livre à d'autres alors les
extraits c'est nous-mêmes vraie question
est ce que oui ou non pour vous frédéric
pierru il ya
une question de souveraineté sur les
données qui peuvent être partagées avec
des cabinets privés voilà qui sont un
problème le health date loeb qui est
devenu le cnds alors c'est quoi c'est là
un gros c'est cette plateforme qui
centralise toutes les données de santé
des français d'accord ça a été
sous-traitée à microsoft chez d'accord
je je je suis quand même dubitatif
sur
la fin de la souveraineté sanitaire qui
on a comme comme géant de l'informatique
d'un géant il fallait on consulte mais
non mais ça d'accord
à la question à qui on confie
les taxis station dépouille l'état si on
le met en position de ne pas accomplir
ou d'internaliser certaines compétences
alors on est dépendant des cabinets de
conseil et j'ajouterais quand même parce
que il ya les 200 millions j'aime
beaucoup françois icalin par ailleurs
j'aime beaucoup son site voilà et je
rends hommage est ce qu'il fait mais
quand même c'est pas seulement des
cabinets conseils mais c'est pas que du
conseil mais le montant des prestations
fournies à l'état et aux hôpitaux par
les grands cabinets de conseil comme
mckinsey où capgemini
s'élève à 14 milliards d'euros en 2019
alors attendez parce que là on est on
est de 150 ans
ça veut dire que l'on a un ça va alors
évidemment il ya l'externalisation il ya
tout ça mais ça veut dire qu'on fait
l'état notre état est de plus en plus
dépendants de société et de firmes
étrangères américaines obéissant aux
droits et extraterritoriale américain et
ça c'est la question du dollar ah il me
semble que c'est une mobilisation afin
de c'est une vraie qui salissent le fait
c'est un quart du budget de l'état et
mais est il semble que on devrait
vite ses 350 milliards le budget de
l'état 14 milliards on est quand même
sur le nom on mélange a fait les gens et
des choeurs
j'y mettais des collectivités l on est
on est on est on est l'état le fait
dépensier au monde voila voila il
pouvait contrer l'insee l ocde si vous
voulez mais c'est si vous donnez pas
mais s'il faut amuser mais le plus élevé
au monde à vous enlever je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire ça je vérifie si je
vais oui ces statistiques a relevé ses
phrases et les régimes au bilan très
bien enfin ça fait partie du public oui
mais oui c'est pas la chute des régimes
de pension tout ça c'est des hippies
la perte de souveraineté en réalité elle
est dans la désindustrialisation par
exemple on peut regretter que microsoft
soit effectivement l'officier traitant
sur les maladies dans les sentiers c'est
le cadre réglementaire qui font autour
de ça et que ces données soient
sécurisés moi j'ai pas fait tant qu'elle
ne sait pas comment ça se passe mais ce
qu'on voit c'est que la perte de
souveraineté aller dans vingt ans de
désindustrialisation
elle est beaucoup plus grave dans 100
milliards de déficit de commerce
extérieur dans la balance net du pays là
les enjeux sont bien supérieurs que sur
quelques conseils donnés chaque année à
l'état
pardon mais je voudrais quand même qu'on
entend de la ministre de la fonction
faire de la transformation et de la
fonction publique amélie de montchanin
qui c'était le le 14 janvier au début de
cette année qui justifiait le recours de
l'état des cabinets de conseil privé on
écoute ce qui est nécessaire c'est que
quand les choses sont complexes ou
puisse s'appuyer sur des compétences qui
puisse nous apporter des points de vue
que l'administration n'a pas elle-même
faire des comparaisons sur les systèmes
logistiques des autres pays nous appuyer
sur l'expérience du sel
ce qui me serait un peu étrange
s'égosillent à la fois on doit tout
faire tout tout seul on doit avoir des
compétences absolument en période de
crise sur des enjeux nouveaux évidemment
qu'ensuite ça nous interroge sur les
compétences sur la formation sur le
recrutement des sujets qu'on va donc
traités sur comment on peut faire que
notre fonction publique soit efficace
mais je ne peux pas être immunisées mans
vous qui considère qu'on ne peut pas
s'appuyer sur d'autres points de vue
c'est pas le principe du recours au
cabinet de conseil que vous critiquent
n'ont pas dû de transparence et je
dirais il faut les interdire non pas du
tout je dirais que c'est la nature et
l'ampleur et aussi je dirais le le
manque de vision parce que nous avons
des outils il faut les conforter tous
talents on dit on a besoin de microsoft
on n'a pas besoin de micro fait on a
l'assurance maladie pour nos cartes
vitale pour notre système non mais ça
existe on a dépensé des fortunes pour ça
regardez dans un autre domaine sans que
ça fonctionne très bien malheureusement
loupé par exemple c'est dans une grande
réussite
et un échec cuisant et est terrible mais
la crise sanitaire était peut-être hamon
c'était peut-être le bon moment pour
essayer d'utiliser ces outils moi je
regrette qu'on ne l'ait pas fait mais on
a d'autres sujets de préoccupation
j'avais dire majeur c'est que la
souveraineté c'est pas simplement sur
les données etc
c'est des fois aussi sur les fonctions
par exemple vous avez des grands groupes
qui ne sont pas français et qui s'occupe
de la santé des français par exemple
ceux qui s'occupent de tout ce qui est
dit à lise reins etc c'est pas une
entreprise qui fabrique des chaussettes
même si c'est très honorable c'est des
choses qui sauve la vie des gens et ça
on n'a plus cette compétence en france
on a aussi des groupes qui qui ne sont
pas français et qui s'occupe de
l'hébergement des plus fragiles des plus
des établissements de santé privés
français qui sont et qui sont acquis qui
appartiennent à des boîtes étrangères
qui appartiennent à des fonds de pension
ça c'est un vrai sujet de souveraineté
si de santé bien sûr des cabinets de
conseil et de la haute fonction publique
parce que c'est quand même le central de
notre belle et si vous voulez un cabinet
de conseil français on les connaît ils
sont pourquoi on ne fait pas appel à des
cabinets de conseil français ça
enlèverait la problématique de la
souveraine mais aussi d'un gemini est
une formidable entreprise
la question que je me pose c'est à
partir du moment où on fait appel à des
cabinets conseils dans à ce niveau et à
cette ampleur on discute des chiffres
etc et en plus en toute opacité puisque
le monsieur de la cour des comptes l'a
dit tout à l'heure il a fallu aller
regarder il n'y a pas de ligne il ya des
marchés qui sont passées de façon c'est
pas bon
qu'est ce qui manque dans notre
administration qu'est ce qui manque dans
notre organisation il manque que ces
choses-là soir content c'est une amie
belle macro jusqu'à ce ministre nommé il
ya une question de dominer qu'est ce
qu'on en juge qu' en tout cas la
fonction publique française n'est pas à
la hauteur et oui mais à ce moment là
on a franchement un problème de niveau
on ad on a quand même personnel
administratif qui est de très grande
qualité en france on a des services
publics extraordinaires alors qu'est ce
qui manque pour que ce soit le mieux
mais je manque peut avoir besoin de
conseils à un moment
média 6 rue est ce qu'il ya des doublons
parfois c'est fou non
je lance ce débat est mal posée à
baliseurs parce que en fait il faut
on a fait deux numéros 2
du de la revue de pierre bourdieu là
dessus sur le conseil de l'état
documenté et c'est
le premier facteur du recours croissant
aux cabinets de conseil c'est le
pantouflage
c'est à dire qu' il ne faut pas être
dupe c'est à dire que en fait on parle
public privé mais en fait je vous prends
des hauts fonctionnaires ou à celle ci
passe dans les cabinets joue pas juste
un exemple
le
responsable conseiller ministériel de
roselyne bachelot en 2009
responsables des agences régionales de
santé
il a à peine fait son boulot il va
direct chez mckinsey
voilà est en fait la réalité c'est que
on a une forme d'hybridation
public privé
de cette haute fonction publique et donc
discuter public-privé me semble être une
discussion réductrice en fait les gens
c'est les revolving doors comme on dit
qui fonctionne à plein en fait voilà
de chine entre
de chine par
tous en même temps mais on reproche
aussi haute fonction publique des
souvent déconnectés de la réalité et on
dit qu'elle a besoin d'aller faire
quelques stages mais il trouvait pour
conquérir enfin les connais je suis
passé chez
séché mme atkins et qu'on apprend la
réalité de terrain déjà qu'on attend la
réalité l'emprise de l'entreprise mon
tout ça c'est des mots un peu un peu
flou la réalité c'est que en réalité le
il ya une forme de fusion d évident
publics et privés
[Musique]
le recours croissant aux cabinets de
conseil et la deuxième chose c'est que
les les recommandations de ces cabinets
de conseils
aboutissent à évider l'état de ses
compétences ou plutôt empêche l'état
d'internaliser des compétences qu'il n'a
pas
et qu'il rendrait plus indépendants 1
par rapport au prix alors comme je suis
têtu que vous avez pas répondu à la
question je vais la reposer mais à
françois ecalle et s'il ya des doublons
parfois c'est à dire que est ce qu'on se
retrouve avec l'état qui - ministère qui
lance une une enquête une mission
publique et puis en parallèle on va
avoir un cabinet de conseil qui fait la
même chose
malheureusement à des doublons de ce
genre à côté le ministère de la santé
qui passe à marcher un cabinet conseil
alors que d'un autre côté le ministère
des finances a section des finances à
des gens qui pourraient remplir cette
mission et c'est la même chose mais si
ça se passe comme ça c'est parce qu'il
est pas si évident que le jour où
ministère de la santé a besoin de telles
prestations à l'inspection des finances
et les trois inspecteurs compétences à
disposition compétent dans ce domaine
qu'ils soient prêts à remplir cette
mission il ya des problèmes
d'organisation qu'il fonde que les
teindre ministère de la santé nous ce
jour là où ce moment là ne peut pas
forcément utiliser ces trois inspecteurs
des finances et donc il va faire appel
en effet décliné consacré à
la fonction publique beaucoup plus
réactif est beaucoup plus flexible alors
parfois c'est une flexibilité exigée
parfois ça se termine mal il disait tant
qu'ils sont capables de le faire alors
qu'en réalité aux mêmes ont des
problèmes pour mobiliser en interne les
gens compétents sur ce domaine et donc
le marché se passe mal finalement mais
souvent ils sont quand même un peu plus
réactif et donc un peu plus disponible
il peut y avoir j'ajouterais aussi
parfois une forme de dilution de la
responsabilité des décideurs publics qui
peuvent se cacher aussi
situation technique ce secteur n'est pas
endosser ses responsabilités
je pense que ça c'est un facteur et
c'est ce que j'avais noté effectivement
je voulais qu'on d'en débattre et je
pense que ça c'est un facteur qui va
vers les conseils étant donné
qu'aujourd'hui on essaye tout le temps à
chaque fois qu'il ya une difficulté de
trouver une responsabilité le fait même
en s'appuyant sur un conseil externe
fait que en fait on est absorbé doit par
définition et ça je crois que c'est un
vrai sujet sont arrivés monte alors je
sais pas dans le budget de 15 % pour un
cabinet de conseil ccsn non non non je
suis bon je dis tu es jeune histoire son
tour de sa lisation autour de cette
table y at il un consultant non non
ben voilà vous avez votre place aux
chaînes et missions non c'est parce que
vous n'en trouverez pas
en fait et ils ne sont que les
commanditaires
enfin les clients de leur patron en fait
et je l' ai vu au moment de la réforme
hpst hôpital patients santé normale oui
mais ils se cachent derrière ça mais ça
pose la question de la responsabilité
politique en fait c'est ça et c'est ce
que disait on à domicile ces fameux la
cour des comptes oui donnerait les
seuils il donne des conseils mais moi
c'est comme les enquêtes de terrain
quand se monte au ministère de la santé
le groupe chargé de
monter les agences régionales de santé
préfigurateurs etc
il ya plus de deux consultants de
capgemini que de hauts fonctionnaires et
moi j'ai interrogé sarm il est
consultant ses amis ni à combien
d'anciens hauts fonctionnaires
c'est une bonne question parce qu'ils se
cachent toujours mais en tout cas tout
ce que je peux dire c'est que les hauts
fonctionnaires disait on avait les
compétences en interne et quand on met
en oeuvre les agences régionales de
santé et c'est là où ça devient
contre-productif c'est que
les powerpoint parce que c'est à st mes
consultants sens pas si bill et au
powerpoint en fait ça braque les
fonctionnaires de terrain
et on termine là dessus merci beaucoup à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous donne rendez vous demain évidemment
pour un nouveau numéro de sens public et
puis